i'm announcing the first tranche of
sanctions these sanctions
are a major step and we hold further
sanctions at readiness to be deployed
the u.s and its allies coordinated a
first round of sanctions against russia
over its troop deployment to breakaway
regions of ukraine
they're hoping the financial pressure
that the sanctions create in russia will
discourage
uh moscow
from going any further into eastern
ukraine or or using his force to take
over the country entirely
the sanctions are expected to have
limited impact on russia's economy but
western governments say they send a
strong signal the u.s blacklisted two
major banks and banned the trade of any
new sovereign debt while some allies
said they would sanction individuals
connected to the breakaway regions and
impose travel bans the political message
that that sends to moscow is hey
you are going to be politically isolated
from from the global economy where all
of these actions will also affect
the
price or the exchange rate of the ruble
but one penalty is sparking concerns for
international energy markets germany's
decision to put the nordstrom 2 pipeline
on hold an 11 billion dollar project
that would bring natural gas directly
from russia to europe
escalation
the us had long called for the
pipeline's opening to be halted and
germany froze the project even though
it's the biggest buyer of russian gas in
the world
the european union also relies on russia
with about 40 of natural gas supplies
coming from there
cutting off future natural gas imports
through the nords nordstrom 2 project
that's already pushed natural gas prices
up five times what they were last winter
that's a big cost that europe didn't
want to take but it also shows how
serious
europe believes the threat of russia's
invasion into eastern ukraine is
russia's foreign ministry called the
actions illegitimate and an effort by
the west to restrain the country's
development as russia contemplates its
next move we have our next move prepared
as well
president biden said there will be
steeper penalties if russia continues
its aggression and launches a full-scale
invasion beyond the breakaway regions
they are a signal to
warn russia that they're serious about
delivering on their threats
but offering moscow an opportunity to
restrain
their own efforts
and that more measured approach
say some analysts allow for a
de-escalation a potential de-escalation
of the tensions
an off-ramp to diplomacy